[Music]
it is the bestselling book in history no
volume ever written has been more loved
and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions our phone lines are open if
you have a Bible related question give
us a call now at 800 God says that's 800
7297 now here's your host from amazing
facts International Pastor Doug Bachelor
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact well it's no
longer the stuff of Star Trek Star Wars
and science fiction in January 2024 the
British Ministry of Defense announced
that they successfully test fired a
laser weapon to take out an aircraft
laser directed energy weapons or ldws
use an intense light beam to cut through
their Target and they can strike at the
speed of light the range of the device
called dragon fire is still classified
but the sophisticated Laser cannon is so
precise it can hit a silver dollar from
a mile away this will be especially
useful to defend against the increasing
number of consumer drones that are being
used in Warfare the dragon fire laser is
not only fast accurate and deadly it's
comparatively inexpensive to operate for
example a typical Tomahawk cruise
missile costs roughly 1.5 million one
missile the dragon fire Cannon can shoot
down a target for roughly $13 in
electricity as I remember Pastor Ross
the Bible says God's got a big laser
that he's going to use at the second
second coming that's right Pastor Doug
it's going to be a gloriously bright
light the Bible says for when it comes
the wicked are destroyed with the
brightness of his coming it the probably
the verse that sounds the most laser
likee is when you read in 2
Thessalonians 2:8 and then the Lawless
one will be revealed whom the Lord will
consume with the breath of his mouth and
notice destroy with the brightness of
his coming something bright happening
there it's kind of like when uh the sons
of Aaron uh naab and Abu it says so fire
went out from the Lord and devoured them
they they went into the sanctuary and
evidently they were drunk and they
brought in Strange Fire and Fire came
down like a laser and then you also have
that verse in Hebrews
10:27 speaking of those that uh reject
God's truth it says but they can only
look forward to fearful expectation of
judgment and fiery indignation that will
devour the adversaries like those that
are destroyed by the brightness of his
coming you know I sometimes use the
illustration that
uh if you go out at night with a
flashlight in the woods and you tip over
a rock you know all of these um creepy
crawlies come out and they they run from
the
light but if you set that light up out
in the field the moths come to the light
so some run from the light and some go
to the light and when Jesus comes
everybody's either a cockroach or a
butterfly that's right has it I actually
Revelation chap 6 describes that it says
the wicked turn the rocks of the
mountains they say Fallen us hide us
from the face of him who sits upon the
throne and from the Wrath of the Lamb so
they're wanting to hide from that
glorious appearing of Christ when he
comes the second time but for the
righteous they look up and say this is
our God we've waited for him he will
save us that's right well you know the
Bible is clear about one thing the world
as we know it is not going to last and
everybody listening right now even if
you're in perfect health you're terminal
these lives are short and all of us will
someday have our last night and there is
going to be a last night on earth we
need to be ready for the end this life
is to prepare for the life that lasts
forever and if you'd like to know how to
prepare we've got a free offer we do
it's a book it's called the last night
on earth and this a free offer for
anyone who watching or listening all you
need to do is call our uh resource phone
line that number is 800
83567 47 you can ask for the book it's
called the last night on earth we'll be
happy to send it to anyone if you're in
the US or in Canada if you're outside of
North America you can just simply go to
the website just amazingfacts.org
there's another way that you can get the
free offer and that is by dialing pound
250 on your smartphone say Bible answers
live and then ask for the book by name
the last night on earth and you know
throughout the program Pastor Doug we're
going to give some other great resources
for people and once again you want to
keep those number keep that number handy
you can call if you have a Bible
question our phone line here to the
studio is 1 800- 463
7297 and our phone lines as they say are
open if you don't get through right away
just stay stay on there and somebody
will take your call as soon as possible
well we're going to start with a word of
prayer and then we'll go to the phone
lines dear father we are grateful once
again for this time that you've given us
to be able to open up the Bible and
study it is the most important book in
the world it reveals truth and so we do
pray for your guidance as we study the
scriptures together in jesus' name amen
amen first caller that we have this
evening is David and he's listening in
California David welcome to Bible
answers
live hi hi
evening um my question tonight is how
long will the tribulation last all right
good question now when we talk about the
tribulation virtually all Christian
denominations agree there is going to be
a very severe tribulation of some sort
prior to the second coming uh Jesus said
that except those days be short and no
flesh would be saved he said for then
shall be Great Tribulation and if you go
to the end of The Book of Daniel it says
at that time this is Daniel chapter 12
Michael will stand up the great Prince
that stands for the children of thy
people and there will be a time of
trouble such as there never has been
since there was a nation even unto the
same time and and many that sleep into
the dust of the earth will awake so
that's the resurrection how long will
this Great Tribulation be now a lot of
people listening right now you probably
heard reference to the seven years of
tribulation actually the phrase seven
years of tribulation does not appear in
the Bible it's presumed and if I'm not
mistaken Pastor Ross that concept is
taken from The Book of Daniel n where
they take the last week of the 490e
prophecy there and they kind of hover it
at the end of time which there's no
other prophecy where you break off part
of it and float it where you want um
some people think that it's seven years
because there were seven days after Noah
entered the
Ark and he was sealed and shut inside
and the wicked were outside their
probation was closed and they thought
you know maybe that's where you can get
seven years of tribulation others have
thought that there'll be now by the way
there's two phases of the time of
trouble you might call one the small
time of trouble that's when you can't
buy or sell then Revelation 13 says
ultimately there is a death decree and
that's very intense that's the seven
last plagues and it's hard to imagine
the life on earth going on for seven
years with the oceans being blood boils
great heat I mean that seems like it's
going to be a condensed period of time
or more concentrated yeah there is a
verse actually it's interesting
Revelation chapter 18:8 we're talking
about the seven last plagues right this
is what the verse says it says therefore
her plagues shall come in one day and
the her there is referring to Babylon
this is the downfall of Babylon we know
that the plagues as described in the
Book of Revelation begins with the sea
turning to blood and all there's a
painful saw and then the sea turns to
blood and so on but we know in Bible
prophecy one prophetic day is equal to
one literal year so that's LED some
Scholars to feel that the seven last
plagues will fall in about the period of
of a year because it says her plague
shall come in one day yeah that's
Revelation 18:8 yeah I can't even
imagine a year like that that'd be a bad
year year it would be so don't worry
about the time of trouble friends just
be faithful day by day is the key and
God promises to take care of his people
that's right during that time now we do
have a book called anything but secret
and the last half of that book talks
about the tribulation and if people
would like a free copy of that we have
the number to call for that is 8835 6747
and you can ask for the book it's called
anything but secret it's one of the
amazing facts study guides but I think
it's also actually that's the book book
that's one of the books uh 800 835 6747
you can dial pound 250 on your
smartphone and ask for the book as well
we have Anna listening in Oregon Anna
welcome to the
program evening pastors
evening my question is what is the true
meaning of speaking in
tongues I'm glad you asked I wish I had
that question more often it's just close
to my heart because when I first became
a Christian all of my friends I worship
ship with were what we would call
charismatic Christians and they
practiced speaking what you would call
speaking in tongues where you know they
would uh ostensibly go into this um
spirit-led trance where they would begin
babbling and muttering and they said
this is a Heavenly language and the
Heavenly prayer language and I'd say
what are you praying this I don't know
or someone might come along and
translate for them and and you know
that's a that's a comparatively new
phenomenon in Christianity the speaking
in tongues that you see in the Bible
first of all you can read in Mark
chapter 16 where Jesus said among the
signs that uh his Spirit would fall upon
them it says they will speak with new
tongues the word tongues means languages
and you see in Acts chapter 2 the
Fulfillment of that when the Holy Spirit
was poured out there were Jews visiting
from all over the Roman Empire on the
day of Pentecost they' come on a
pilgrimage and the lord gave the TW
Apostles and others in the upper room
the supernatural ability to speak
languages they did not formally know or
study for the purpose of preaching the
gospel to these visiting Jews other
times in the uh early days of the church
people were given the the gift of
tongues to speak in languages they did
not know see at the Tower of Babel God
cursed man and there was confusion they
couldn't understand at Pentecost he
reversed the curse and gave the
disciples the ability ability to
communicate the gospel in any language
but they were real languages of the
world it doesn't say that they just
babbled or muttered Paul says in 1
Corinthians
14 uh except you utter by the Tongue
words to be easy easy to be understood
no one will know what you're saying
you're speaking into the air Paul said
I'd rather speak five words where by my
tongue I might educate or teach someone
than 10,000 in a language someone
doesn't understand so um we got a gift
book on it I could say much more but I'd
launch into number 36 so better say
there that's right our book is called
understanding tongues and we'll be happy
to send it to anyone who calls and asks
again the number is 800 835 6747 or you
can dial pound 250 ask for Bible answers
live if you're going to use your phone
and say I want the book called
understanding tongues and we'll be happy
to send it to anyone again in North
America if you're outside of the US just
go to our website amazingfacts.org next
caller that we have is Ryan and he's
listening in New Mexico Ryan welcome to
Bible answers
live hello how y'all doing today doing
good thanks for
calling um my question is well I had a
question last week about um uh is does
Jesus did he use two different calendars
and I really didn't uh I don't know I
didn't I guess I didn't really
understand the answer but my question
this week is is keeping the Sabbath on
the Pagan Roman Calendar the Gregorian
calendar 7day cycle uh is that it only
uses the sun is that actually Sun
worship I I mean because it's it's only
dealing with the Sun that sday cycle um
I think you know Pagan Rome got that
from the Looney the Looney solar
calendar you know what I mean um yeah
would that not be Faller Sun
worship here let me jump in here uh
you've got two calendars when Jesus was
born Julius Caesar had already lived and
died when Jesus was born and they were
using what they called the Julian
calendar and you know the the calendar
names that we use and even the names for
the days of the week we get most of that
from the Romans uh the Romans got some
of it influenced by the Greeks and you
could even Trace some of it back maybe
to Babylon but the the days of the um
the week the day of the sun is Sunday
the day of the moon is Monday so forth
you know Wednesday was Odin's day
Thursday was Thor's day Saturday was
Saturn day in the Bible they never used
any of the Roman names they use first
day second day third day now we know
what the days of the week are the Romans
had a 7-Day week and the Jews had a
7-Day week and we all have a 7-Day week
the 7-Day week of the Romans the first
day of of the Jews was what the Romans
call Sunday or we call Sunday and even
in the Bible we know Jesus rose the
first day of the week it's not Sun
worship if we're using a calendar for
keeping appointments uh about what time
of year it is for planting or whatever
what are you going to call the months
you going to use the Jewish names for
the months
but the calendar never affects the
weekly cycle now it doesn't matter
whether you're using the Julian calendar
when they switch from the Julian
calendar to the Gregorian calendar you
can help me Pastor Ross you've done this
meeting before it was October 5 Thursday
15 uh 82 I think and then it went the
next day went to October 15 Friday so
they went all the way from the 5th to
the 15th they dropped in when they
switched from the Julian to the
Gregorian calendar but they went from
Thursday to Friday so while they made a
jump and a change in the calendar it
never affected the weekly cycle Thursday
was followed by Friday is that right
well yeah you said 1582 what was it
let's see the change from the Julian to
G Gregorian calendar occurred 1582 let
me see it doesn't give us the exact I'm
looking this up I'm pretty sure about
the October yeah October 4 was followed
by October 15 in October 45 yeah they
added 10 days all right I got that wrong
I said October 5 so but Thursday was
followed by Friday so I don't know if
that helps Ryan answer your question but
uh I don't consider it sun worship if
you know it's the only calendar the
world follows right now and um it dates
back before the time of Christ Jesus
didn't follow a calendar Jesus lived by
um the weekly cycle as far as what they
Sabbath that was same seven days we keep
now in different languages use different
names obviously for the days of the week
it is interesting though in a number of
languages that the seventh day of the
week that we call Saturday today is
actually sabad if it's Spanish or a
number of other languages in Russian
yeah that's right which connects to the
Hebrew yeah very interesting okay next
caller that we have is Wade listening in
Minnesota Wade welcome to the
program yeah hi Pastor Doug um I just
wanted to say that your testimony is the
most powerful I've ever heard and uh
thank you I just wanted you to know that
but um the question I have is about 2
Timothy
2:15 where uh the Apostle Paul talks
about rightly dividing the word of Truth
is he talking about studying the Bible
dispensation or what's uh what's he
talking about there well I think Paul's
comment uh and this is it says be
diligent to present yourself approve to
God a worker who does not need to be
ashamed rightly dividing the word of
Truth well when you're teaching truth
from the
scriptures uh you don't want to use uh
goofy comparisons like you know I heard
a pastor say once you know you could
find the verse that says Judas went out
and hung himself Bible does say that and
then you can jump to a verse that says
go thou do likewise well that's not
rightly dividing the word of Truth
telling telling people that you're
supposed to go hang yourself like Judas
because youve patched together two
scriptures you've not divided it rightly
so dividing it rightly means comparing
scriptures and themes with appropriate
or similar scriptures or themes to teach
a point so that you're Faithfully
teaching things in
context um and staying with the the uh
essence of what the truth would be you
know we have a book it's called the
ultimate resource and it's all about the
Bible it talks about how to study the
Bible I'll be happy to send it to anyone
who calls and asks the number 800 835
6747 just ask once again for that book
it's called the ultimate resource it's
all about the Bible you can D pound 250
on your smartphone and say Bible answers
live and then ask for the book by name
thank you Wade we got Shannon listening
in Georgia Shannon welcome to the
program oh thank you um my question is
Psalms one through three um it mentions
David um fighting against a unknown
group and what I wanted to know is if
there's anywhere listed in the Bible
that I can find out who these people
were you said Psalms 1
through3 um Psalm 60 oh Psalm 60 veres 1
through3 yes okay and let me read that
for our friends oh God you've cast us
off you have broken us down you have
been displeased oh restore us again
you've made the Earth to tremble you've
broken it heal its breaches for it is is
shaking you've shown your people hard
things you have made us drink the wine
of confusion now keep in mind uh David
did not write all of the Psalms he
probably I think he wrote 70 of them if
I'm not mistaken Pastor Ross some were
written by ASF and some maybe even
Solomon the Bible says wrote some Psalms
um when it says you made us drink the
wine of confusion it's interesting it
talks about the wine of Babylon in uh is
that the Revelation 17 Pastor Ross
babylon's made the Nations drunk with
her wine y Revelations and this could be
an illusion to one of the many times the
children of Israel were conquered
because of their unfaithfulness by some
surrounding Nation it doesn't say what
that nation is oh wait a second now I
take it back it says um in I wasn't
reading the preface to the psalm a mitch
of David for teaching when he fought
against Mesopotamia and Syria of zoba
and joab returned and killed 12,000
in the valley of salt yeah I
remember that was when joab fought one
group and he sent his brother adonijah
to fight the other group they got kind
of attacked from the North and the South
at one time and U they look like I think
David is kind of pleading here for
victory but they won that battle they
did yeah all right very good well thank
you Shannon we've got Lee in Texas Lee
welcome to the
program yes sir good evening evening my
question for my question for the night
would be what does it mean by the man of
sin will takes takes his seat in the
temple of God is that in Rome or is that
in
Jerusalem I think it's in Rome because
um when it says that he sits in the
temple of God showing himself that he is
God of course there is no Hebrew Temple
now but Jesus said destroy this Temple
made with hands and is that John uh what
verse is that uh I know it's the Gospel
of John is that John 6 destroy this
Temple made with hands and in three days
I will make one without hands and it
says he spoke of his body the church is
called the body of Christ and the Bible
says we are living stones built up to a
spiritual house uh so when you talk
about someone sitting in the temple of
God showing himself that he is God it's
talking about someone sitting over the
church saying they hold some Divine
position and many Protestants believe
that's speaking of what the Roman
pontiff did John chapter 2: 19 Jesus
said destroy this temple in three days
I'll raise it up again Y and of course
he spoke not only of his body but he
also spoke of the New Testament Church
yeah and there is no place really for
any person to sit and rule in the temple
that was in Jerusalem of course it was
destroyed in 70 AD but when you compare
that to the church and like you mention
the city of Rome yes there is a king
that actually rules from that church
that cathedral which was never the cas
as related to Jerusalem and the temple
there yeah the Jewish temple had no
throne room that's right it just had a
place for the the ark but you and I were
in the Vatican right in the very heart
of of the church and there's a big place
for the throne between two angels that's
right okay well thank you Lee we've got
Robert listening in Washington Robert
welcome to the
program hi good evening
evening thank you for being here
tonight well praise the Lord we're glad
that we can uh study the word with our
friends yes um as you might see on your
note this is it's a little bit different
question than I had tonight um regarding
the history SL U Bible um I was
discussing um the second coming the
signs of the second coming with with a
friend and um regarding May 1780 the the
dark day and then the falling of the
stars and she was saying telling me that
um well how do you know that may 1780 is
is the dark day I mean she was saying
well there's been many dark days there's
been many times that the Stars fell from
heaven so how can you
pinpoint um these two dates can can you
possibly help me with that yeah um well
keep in mind that uh
prophecy has a historical application so
Jesus wanting the church to know when
his coming was near he would give uh
major signs in history now in Matthew 24
he said that there would be a great
earthquakes that the sun would turn dark
the moon would turn to blood the Stars
would fall to Heaven those things have
happened on a historic timeline in a
very significant way I mean you can go
to the encyclopedia or even on Google
and if you say what was the day of the
great star falling it'll take you to was
it 333 yeah uh I think it's May 1833
Abraham Lincoln even comments on that
because he saw it it was a quite a
significant event and when you talk
about the dark day that was something
that's in the history books and this is
all happening and then the lisman
earthquake that was maybe not the most
intense but it was one of the most
widely felt earthquakes as far as its
geography that was 175
1755 Eliz earthquake you know what also
is interesting is the way Jesus mentions
it there in Matthew 24 he talks about an
earthquake he talks about the sun
becoming dark the Moon being as blood
and then the Stars falling from heaven
and right around that time period 1755
yeah the Lisbon earthquake uh which was
felt they say on three continents Africa
Europe and even as far away as North
America uh and then you had the dark day
as we mentioned in 17 when was that date
that came a little later 1780 then you
have the Lenard uh meteor shower in 1833
and all of these are announcing the
coming of a day of judgment and we
understand that to have taken place at
the end of the 2300 days in 1844 yeah
according to Daniel 8:14 so these are
significant events that point to a
fulfillment of Prophecy right and they
understood that even back in those times
there's many historical records of when
this day suddenly turned dark people
began to wonder well is this the end of
the world and when the stars fell people
were wondering well is this a warning
that God is giving so they understood
the the significance of these events
yeah and then of course these things are
going to happen again in quick
succession at the second coming because
uh one thing that hasn't happened it
also says in the heavens will depart as
a scroll and then they will see the sign
of the son of man so not only did these
things happen historically to kind of
wake people up and tell us we're we're
marching to the end and keep in mind you
know a day with the Lord is like a
thousand years you look at the scope of
Bible History and it moves you know
slowly for our lives but historically
we're nearing the end but they're going
to happen in quick succession right at
the end of time also okay thank you
Robert we've got will listening in
Canada will welcome to the
program good evening pastors
evening so um my question is in 1 samel
chapter 10 verse 10 uh does prophecy has
a different meaning in this context
well let me read this for our friends
first you said 1st Samuel
10:10 says when they came to the hill
there was a group of prophets to meet
him and the spirit of God Came Upon him
and he prophesied among
them well the word prophesy there it
means he preached he be the spirit of
God came over him and he began to
testify and and preach and talk about
the glory of God and praise God and you
see that happening in 1 Corinthians
14 UL Paul said it's better to prophesy
than speak in tongues and it says that U
the Evangelist Philip had four daughters
which did prophesy they didn't walk
around for telling the future it means
he had four daughters that also taught
they may have taught other women but he
had four daughter daughters that were
also involved in a Teaching Ministry and
so uh prophecy didn't mean you know
Elijah was a prophet but he didn't spend
all his time talking about the future
neither did John the Baptist he said
repent and so that's probably the kind
of Prophecy Saul who had been a king a
benjamite spirit of the Lord comes on
him and he begins to prophesy which is
something that the priests and the the
sons of the prophets normally did does
that help uh answer that
question yeah thank you all right hey
thanks so much you know Pastor Ross
we're gonna have a break in no about 30
seconds here so I we don't want to take
a call and cut people off short uh
sometimes we'll start a call at the
beginning of a break and take it at the
end but sometimes when people sign on
and off they lose context but uh friends
we're going to go um probably get a
drink of water we want you to tell your
friends that the best part of the
program is still coming and don't forget
you can also be listening to and
watching everything we do on the Amazing
Facts YouTube channel so don't go away
we'll be back in a
moment stay tuned Bible answers live
will return
shortly
the US government is drowning in debt to
the tune of$ 22 trillion but before you
wag your finger at the government's
spending the Federal Reserve says the
average American household carries over
$137,000 in debt well it was never God's
plan that we live with a burden of debt
Proverbs 227 warns us the rich rules
over the poor and the borrower is
servant to the lender living with debt
is a stressful burden that actually
hurts your relationship with God in my
new pocketbook deliverance from debt I
outline the Bible principles on how to
properly manage your money with some
practical suggestions and how you can
get out and stay out of debt if you or
someone you love is drowning in debt
order a copy of Deliverance from debt
today it can be a lifesaver to keep you
from going under please call
85387 275 or visit AF bookstore.com
[Music]
Jerusalem the city of Peace has been a
place of unending Conflict for centuries
many now believe that Jerusalem will
soon take Center Stage again but what
does the Bible say the fall and Rise of
Jerusalem presents the vital history you
need to know about Jerusalem and its
role in Endtime Bible prophecy this
amazing facts edition of the classic
volume the great controversy is the
perfect sharing book get your copy at AF
bookstore.com
every year 40,000 souls in North America
end their own lives suicide is a
terrible tragedy and while it's
difficult to talk about we need to face
it together as Christians that's why in
my new book choosing life I share the
biblical perspective about suicide
answering some difficult questions about
faith and salvation along the way and
offering practical tips that should help
and encourage others Jesus wants us to
choose an abundant life in him
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life
[Music]
today if you have a question about the
Bible or living the Christian Life call
us now at 800 God says that's 8004 46
37297 now let's rejoin our hosts for
more Bible answers
live welcome back listening friends to
Bible answers live we know there's some
that have joined along the way this is a
live International interactive Bible
study we are not only uh streaming on
the internet and Facebook and YouTube
but we're on about 300 radio stations
satellite radio and all you have to do
is call in with your Bible questions and
we'll do our best to take as many calls
as we can can sometimes I think folks
might think well I wanted a longer
answer but we see the line of people
waiting we try and budget about 3
minutes get as many calls as we can and
just to teach the word of God if you
want to call in with a question it's 800
God says that's 800 463 7297 I am Doug
Bachelor my name is John Ross and we
have Ian listening from uh no actually
it's Ivan I think from
Mexico let's see Ivan are you there
evening pastors evening yes
good evening past how you doing thank
you for taking my call good thanks for
calling um I have a question I wanted to
I had a question in regards to uh the
Deliverance of uh evil
spirits how do we go by getting
delivered by uh from those
things yeah well the um of course Jesus
casts out spirits and so by turning to
the Lord and asking for deliverance uh
it helps if you go to Christian friends
uh I mean if if you're the person you're
talking about you might be thinking
about someone else you go to Christian
friends and you can gather and pray now
if the person that is tormented they may
choose to come themselves like the
demoniac in Mark chapter 5 he came to
Jesus Jesus cast out the evil spirits
turn your life over to him through the
proclamation of the word Jesus um
basically sets us free and through
prayer and so you know sometimes the
disciples would pray over somebody and
the the evil spirits would leave them
and you know it might be a battle that
goes on for a while even Jesus it says
he cast Seven Devils out of Mary
Magdalene and it seems to indicate that
seven times she kind of slid back so um
it's it's coming through the turning to
the Lord through the uh reading and the
proclamation of the word and through
prayer and if there is something in your
life that you know is out of harmony
with the will of God maybe there's
movies or books talking about the occult
or maybe you know there's things in your
house that should not be there that
gives a foothold to the devil or to an
evil spirit we want to get rid of that
as well so do everything we can do in
our power but ultimately Deliverance
does come through prayer and like Pastor
Doug says the Bible says with two or
three are gathered together in my name
that's where I will be so get Godly
friends or church members and unite in
prayer and ask God to do something that
you know you can't do for yourself
that's right okay thank you next caller
that we have is Rebecca Rebecca is
listening in Washington Rebecca welcome
to the
program hi thank you so much pastors I
appreciate being here yes how can we
help
you hi Pastor Doug I I sent you the ice
maiden's kiss thank you for sending me
that uh devotional oh okay thank you I
remember
that yeah yeah um and I just wanted to
ask about in Proverbs um there's a a lot
of references to wisdom as she and her
and I've been asked by other people you
know not Believers um why that is and if
if Solomon is referencing the Holy
Spirit and if so why would he be
referencing uh she and her uh proverbs 4
5-9 and then again down in 13 well he
does both so you're right in proverbs 4
and uh in five
it says you know wisdom cries out but
you go to Proverbs chap 8 and here it
not only says she cries out by the gates
but then you get down a little later and
it says he was with me in the beginning
of his ways and so I think the reason
it's going back and forth is because
it's it's trying to talk about a love
relationship that we are to love wisdom
and so it kind of Compares it to a
marriage you want to be married to it
and things that yeah a great value talks
about wisdom is better than rubies
better than gold talks about you know
this wisdom is described as a woman or
it's described as a wise man so there's
different phrases that's used different
symbols that's used to illustrate the
importance of wisdom which ultimately
comes through the Holy Spirit yep yeah
I'm also looking again in uh Proverbs 8
it says I wisdom dwell with prudence and
the counsel is mine uh by me King's
Reign so you know I think Solomon
probably is drawing on every beautiful
analogy he can think of in talking about
wisdom as something precious okay thank
you we got guy listening in Arizona guy
welcome to the
program yeah thank you for taking my
call I appreciate it yes sir uh I'll get
right to the point years ago when I got
out of military I was going to college
and met a young lady from Tran Iran a
beautiful lady and um
introduced her to my family and
everything she seemed okay so we got
married and uh she bore me three
children one boy and then a set of twin
boys and uh all through our relationship
she never did kiss me uh you know they
removed the curus when they're born in
uh the moim countries and she told me of
a terrible happenings in uh and when she
was going to high school and stuff and
anyway
we had the children and or she had the
children and um she never did uh we
weren't compatible uh I slept in another
bedroom she wouldn't U she wouldn't have
nothing to do with me then she worked
for her brother in a bar and that really
turned me off well what's the Bible
question you got to sum it up okay yeah
Okay I uh we got separated I was 600
miles north because we got separated and
um I was upset and uh then I learned
that uh I got a call that she had sent
my children took my children to Tran
Iran I was outraged I had just made a
claim on a gold mine I went inside this
gold mine picked up a big chunk of gold
it was uh really nice and I okay we're
still for the B threw it against the
wall I threw it against the wall and I
cursed out the Holy
Spirit since then I've repented and I've
asked for forgiveness for that stupid
action because I was outraged and I'm
wondering have I been
forgiven okay so you you got uh very
upset and you verbally cursed against
the Holy Spirit and you wonder if if you
repent of that can you be forgiven yes
that is not blasphemy against the Holy
Spirit uh there are people who are are
in a stage of grief where they have a
great deal of anger maybe they've lost a
loved one and they say very very
Reckless things it sounds like you are
going through a personal
crisis and um then then you know they
they weren't really in their right minds
they're very angry sometimes the devil
gets a hold of us and we say things we
should never say can God forgive you if
you sincerely repent he will absolutely
forgive you you know we have a book
Pastor D called what is the unpardonable
sin and I think you'd enjoy that guy
it'll help clarify what the Bible means
when it talks about blasphemy against
the Holy Spirit just call and ask for it
and we'll send it to you it's 800 835
6747 that is our free offer or you can
dial pound 250 on your smartphone say
Bible ances live and then ask for the
book what is the unpardonable sin and
we'll send that to you yeah we've got
Jason listening in Washington Jason
welcome to the
program hi thank you my question is is
it ever okay to threaten someone with
violence if they're doing something like
um uh insulting your mother or wife or
um and this would be a man doing it or
they're contacting them when they've
asked them not
to no I don't think it's ever now I want
to make a distinction here if if you or
your family are physically threatened
you might need to do something physical
to protect them but uh even if someone
you know Jesus said if someone just gets
angry and Strikes you on the right cheek
you can offer him the other now he's not
talking about a boxing match he's saying
someone gets mad and swings at you um
but because of words spoken I don't
think Christians should react with
violence on any occasion you look at
Howes Jesus he got buffeted and U he he
bore it patiently
um you know people are going to Mock You
Jesus said pray for those who
despitefully use you and persecute you
love your enemies overcome evil with
good he doesn't want us to overcome evil
with evil and so no I don't think you
should resort to violence when someone
says something rude or unkind or even
insulting that's right all right very
good thank you we've got T listening in
Virginia T welcome to the program
thank you and good evening and just
really quickly you all your ministry is
amazing and I thank God for you all
every single day oh my question is
you're welcome um my question is is it
adultery for a Christian to do the sign
of the
cross yeah we know that uh a lot of our
Catholic Brethren there may be some
other churches that you'll see them
cross themselves at the end of a prayer
or you know at some moment of uh crisis
and um there's nothing in the Bible that
tells us to do that that is something
that I think kind of grew out of a pagan
tradition um I you know I don't think we
ought to be doing it as Christians
because the the um there's so many Pagan
trappings to those things now I don't
know Pastor Ross I can't think of any
Bible example of a person making the
physical sign of the cross or or going
through any kind of spiritual Gest we
have no record of any of that until well
like you say the Middle Ages where some
Pagan ideas began to make its way into
Christianity and some of these remnants
of doing certain things or saying
certain prayers uh that was introduced
into the church and I think that's where
making the sign of the cross came from
as well and you get into some of the
secret societies they give special
secret hand gestures and things I can't
think of an example I mean the only
thing in the Bible it says they lifted
their hands in prayer yep and you know
there are examples in the Bible where
they they bowed in prayer and they
closed their eyes in prayer and you that
would be biblical but making a sign of
the cross prior to praying or ending
that's not biblical yeah anyway thank
you appreciate that t and thanks for the
uh encouragement we've got uh Steve
listening in Oregon Steve welcome to the
program hello um thank you so much for
taking my call say when did the Bible
get divided into verses and punctuation
was added and by who like like which
institution you recommend it one of your
um amazing facts Publications or
website you know we just did a series on
the history of the Bible and they I
don't think they happened at the same
time um I think that the division of
chapters and verses was a separate event
to when the translators went through and
added English punctuation now you
realize of course punctuation in
different languages is all going to be
different so because Greek had no
punctuation they had to decide where you
would put the comma in the period um
Hebrew had a different kind of
punctuation their whole structure was
different they actually read from right
to left so uh the translation of the two
from Greek and from Hebrew was different
and happened at different times the
Hebrew Old Testament was translated to
English English before I believe the
wickliff got to the New Testament and I
don't know if he was one of the first
ones to add punctuation coming from into
yes somewhat but as far as the the most
known I guess punctuation wasn't until
the 1550s okay just before the printing
of the Geneva Bible which was in 1560
and that's where more punctuation was at
and I think it was at that point as well
where they they began to clarify
different passages with verses so that
it would be easier for people to find if
they're reading it together so it really
took hold when the printing press began
to print and people were translating
more and more stuff into
English there you have it I hope that
helps a little you know we do have the
book it's called the ultimate resource
and it's all about the Bible and give
you a lot more information about the
history of the Bible how to study the
Bible the number to call for that is
8835 6747 and just ask for that book
it's called the ultimate resource next
caller that we have is Steve listening
in Canada Steve welcome to the uh to
Bible answers
live hello hi can help yes you're on um
good evening uh my question well I'm
somewhat confused um as to the author of
the book of um Romans because um in
Romans um 20 U 16 Verse 22 it says
because I always thought that um Paul
wrote Romans but in Romans 16 ver vers
22 says
I um Tios wrote this epistle greet you
in the Lord mhm well yeah tertius was
the
Scribe but the dictation and the message
is coming directly from Paul because you
go into the first Paul had problems with
his eyes evidently he talks about a
thorn in his side and of course he was
struck blind when he first saw the Lord
but you look in the first verse in the
Book of Romans says Paul a bond servant
of Jesus Christ called to me an apostle
separated so it's a message from Paul uh
Paul was I think he was in jail a lot of
the time and he also dictated things to
scribes sometimes Paul would dictate a
letter and he'd say I'm signing this in
my own hand so it would be he would
authorize it and he said you know behold
with what large characters I'm writing
he wrote very big Paul when he was being
tried by the high priest he called him a
Whited wall and the guard said you're
going to
say that to the high priest and he's
squinting and going I didn't know it was
the high priest he couldn't see so I I
think that um it's just telling us that
tius was the uh the Scribe secretary who
wrote it out and he sends a little
greeting at the end in his own hand all
right thank you Steve again you might
like that book called The Ultimate
resource talks about the Bible number to
call for that is 800 835
6747 Jennifer is listening in New York
Jennifer welcome to Bible answers five
thank you good evening and and God bless
you pastors thank you in Genesis 19 we
read where where Min lot was in Sodom
and the angels came to
him he said they they wanted to re the
the guys the angels and lot said he will
sent out two of his his two daughters
who knew no man there were virgins but
in verse 14 we read where lot went out
to speak to his sons-in-laws who were
married to his daughters so my question
is if they were married how could they
they could have been virgins at a time
well it's talking about lot evidently
had other daughters some of them were
married it doesn't tell us if it was two
or three it uses the plural so he had
other daughters that were married and um
it's interesting that just the contrast
between lot and Noah I don't know if
you've ever done that Noah had sons and
he saved his family loah lot had
daughters and they got they married off
and Noah separated and stayed with the
Lord and lot went down to the wrong City
and just an interesting contrast but um
uh yeah it's just basically talking
about the daughters that were married
and the two youngest that were not
married were virgins and the ones who
were married apparently they were
destroyed his wife and his two daughters
that were taken out specifically me
mentions his sons-in-law yeah that
mocked they thought he was U mocking all
right thank you Jennifer we've got um
kimbery in Nevada kimbery welcome to the
program hello hi hi um my question um is
um also from Genesis um first of all
thank you for taking my call but um so
in um chapter 15 um verses 9 and 10 when
um Abraham is making the covenants yes
um and it talks about the ram the heer
and um the birds um my question is what
is the um significance of the birds and
why were the birds not split in half
yeah well typically the the larger
offerings were
dissected uh the birds were so small
that you know when uh sometimes when
they butchered the bigger animals they
would divide it up and they would
dissect them like that the birds were so
small it was like one per person they
just they didn't divide them up mhm um
and I think that's the main reason and
and even when they were drying meat
sometimes they dry it in the sun you
know bigger sections takes longer to dry
they split it up so it'll dry more
quickly a little bird you could just
hang it up and it would dry just salt it
like the fish so yeah they didn't divide
them but they took the offerings from
the poorest is what the birds offered to
the richest which would have been the
heer and a goat kind of in
between okay thank you we've got Chris
listening in Alabama Chris welcome to
the
program yes thank you uh I just want to
get right straight to it the Jacob
married the Two
Sisters yes uh has anybody ever thought
that they might have been
twins no because laan well someone may
have thought it but laan specifically
says we never marry the younger before
the older uh it it always talks about
Rachel being younger and Le being older
never says they were twinss I think it
would have mentioned that especially
since it does mention that Jacob was a
twin and ferah and Zarah were twins but
um yeah I think that there it delineates
that Rachel was the
younger all right thank you Chris we've
got Greg in California Greg welcome to
Bible answers
live good evening pastors uh thank you
for taking my call yes um Pastor Doug I
heard you speak uh Sabbath morning and
you were talking about the uh Holy
Spirit and you said to be saved at the
very end you said to be saved you must
be born of the spirit and so my question
is is are you born of the spirit at the
moment you accept Christ as your savior
and and if not when are you born of the
spirit yeah well I think definitely when
you accept Jesus uh it's usually the
Holy Spirit working in your heart that
leads you to repentance so the spirit is
working in your heart to just even bring
you to the point of repentance and
turning to God and when you turn and
give your life to the Lord I think the
Holy Spirit uh begins working in your
heart definitely um at
baptism because then you surrendered and
obeyed and you've made that commitment
because it says repent be baptized and
you shall receive the gift of the Holy
Spirit and even Jesus at his baptism he
came out of the water but you've got
Cornelius in Acts chapter 10 he's
baptized with the holy spirit before he
baptized with water so you can
definitely have the Holy Spirit and I
think most people are born again before
they ever get baptized in the spirit
that's what leads them to repent and to
become a have a new heart so what do you
think Pastor Ross absolutely you know
Jesus said it's like the blowing of the
wind you might not be able to give a
specific moment but it's the holy spirit
that works the Bible says it's the
goodness of God that leads us to
repentance repentance to be born of the
Holy Spirit you know we might not always
be able to point to an exact moment some
people can very dramatic conversion
experience but for others it's a gradual
drawing to the Lord absolutely all right
thank you next that we have is uh Robert
in Michigan Robert welcome to Bible
answers live thank you for taking my
call my question involves two verses in
the Bible Matthew 12:36 where it says uh
but Every Idle word that men shall speak
they shall give account thereof in the
day of judgment and then another verse
is in Romans 14:10 where it says for we
all shall stand before the Judgment seat
of Christ and so I wonder how literal
this is and in that context if it is
literal when or when will the redeemed
person ever give account for anything
because aren't is aren't they covered by
Jesus well yes um the Bible says that
all are judged and that means everybody
and even the redeemed they're being
judged to show where they redeemed you
know did they surrender their lives to
the Lord did they have the fruits of the
spirit uh did they you know follow up on
their commitment now keep in mind for
our friends listening Jesus said that
you'll give an account in the Judgment
for every Idol word you spoke for one
thing that means we need to be careful
of what we say but everybody here is
doomed if if there's no mercy because
everybody has said things they shouldn't
say so we have to trust in the Lord's
Mercy or nobody's going to going to have
any hope and Paul is just warning us
that uh there is a day where everybody
gives an account now for those that have
repented and turned from their sins we
are covered and we are under the blood
of Jesus and we are pardoned by his
grace um otherwise we may as well just
turn off the electricity right now and
go home this program would be useless
it's only God's grace that gives us any
hope you know these a verse that we
reading 1 Timothy 5: 24 where Paul says
some men's sins are clearly evident
preceding them to judgment but those of
some men follow later meaning that if we
confess our sins yes they preced us to
judgment but those sins are blotted out
our names are retained in the Lamb's
Book of Life but if we get it to the
judgment and we haven't con confessed
our sins our sins follow us so to speak
and our names end up getting blotted out
of the lamp's book of life so you want
to send your sins beforehand to the
Judgment that they can be blotted out
good point great verse okay thank you
next caller that we have have is uh Neil
listening in California or Nell n
welcome to the
program hi thank you for taking my call
I have a question should Christians
invest in like uh say like the S&P 500
considering that there might be
companies in there that um you know
provide items that Christians would not
take part of how should a Christian
invest yeah that is a good question uh
you know at some point every Christian
needs to realize that uh you may you may
invest in um a bank when you put your
money in a bank you are basically
investing in the bank because they take
your money they don't sit on it in a
safe somewhere they take your money and
they invest in a broad spectrum of
stocks you're not responsible for that
you're just you know putting your money
at a bank and even Jesus recommends that
for example uh I don't want to support a
tobacco or alcohol industry but let's
face it every time you you go to Walmart
or any Supermarket they sell these
things that a Christian shouldn't use
well I can't let that I can't U torture
my conscience because of everything that
a supermarket might sell I'd never find
a supermarket to shop at and so when you
make an investment if you buy a mutual
fund fortunately now there are some
where you could say I want to buy they
call them the uh a sin-free or an
ethical fund there are some funds that
do not invest in the entertainment or
the tobacco companies but I I wouldn't
say that a person should feel concerned
about investing in like the NASDAQ or
the S&P that's just a broad it's like
having your money in a bank it's kind of
a broad fund I don't think we should
speculate or gamble some people are
trading every day it's almost like
gambling but um the Lord tells us that
we should be wise in our investment
don't bury our talent uh otherwise he's
going to say we're lazy servants said
you should have at least put it in the
bank so i' get my interest
I hope that makes some sense n thank you
um yeah we're surrounded as Christians
with these moral dilemmas all the time
Pastor Ross where we've got to just pray
God gives us wisdom we make good
judgment but uh we also have to be able
to negotiate our way through this world
for our listening friends uh we sign off
in two stages we say farewell first so
those listening on satellite and thank
you for tuning in for the rest if you
stay by we're coming back in a moment
with our online rapid fire Bible
questions God bless to the
rest thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California Hello friends and welcome
back to Bible answers live for those of
you who stayed by we going to take some
of your email email questions if you'd
like to send us an email question the
email address is B questions
amazingfacts.org Pastor Doug Glenda is
asking why did God say that eating
swine's flesh is an Abomination is it
spiritual or
symbolic well both uh for one thing um
pigs are
scavengers and our bodies of the Temple
of the Holy Spirit you never brought an
unclean animal into the temple uh
secondarily it so there's a command that
are unclean as food as well because they
are scavengers it was never God's plan
for us to eat any meat A man was made to
be a vegetarian in the Garden of Eden
and he finally said look if you're going
to eat meat they must be classified in
the clean category and and pigs are
called pigs because they're pigs I
they're an Abomination you shouldn't eat
them they might make nice pets like dogs
but don't eat dogs either all right
Kathy's asking can you please explain
what it means in the Bible when it
refers to Jesus as the son of David
isn't he the Son of God yeah well he's
both uh Jesus was conceived by the Holy
Spirit but he also his mother was a
human and both Mary and Joseph came from
the line of David God made a promise to
David in I think it's 1 Chronicles
chapter 17 that through his Descendants
the Messiah would come the Savior would
be a son of David and every Jew knew
that when Jesus came they called him the
son of David they were basically saying
you're the Messiah all right d Diane
is's asking what does it mean to be
absent from the body and to be present
with the Lord yeah and that's coming to
us from 1 Corinthians is a chapter 5 and
you could start with verse six so we are
always confident knowing that while
we're at home in the body we're absent
from the Lord for we walk by faith and
not by sight we're confident yes will
please rather to be absent from the body
and present with the lord well when a
Believer dies their next conscious
thought is the resurrection and they'll
be in the presence of the Lord but until
the resurrection
like Lazarus Jesus said he's asleep we
sleep a dreamless sleep for our loved
ones that die we can be praising God for
their benefit because we know their next
conscious thought is the resurrection
but it hasn't happened Paul's also doing
a what you call like a double on tandre
here in that he's saying if you live in
the spirit and you're absent from the
body the flesh you're walking with the
Lord so he's also doing a play on words
here as well uh I don't know that now 17
seconds I can't do another question we
hope you're going to give us another
chance next week listening Friends check
out our Amazing Facts website a lot of
things going on and coming up
amazingfacts.org God willing we'll study
his word with you again next
[Music]
week